قال موقع ريبار العسكريه الروسيه
اقتحام الدفاعات الجيش الاوكراني شمالي
مدينه
وتتقدم بشكل متزامن من المحور الجنوبي
للمدينه واوضح الموقع ان القتال بين
فاجنير والجيش الاوكراني يتركز في منطقتي
كراسني وبودي نوفا جنوب غرب المدينه
واضاف موقع ريبار ان القوات الروسيه وبدعم
من الطيران والمدفعيه الثقيله توغلت من
الجهه الشماليه باتجاه محطه القطارات
ستوبكي وتخوض معارك قرب بلده بيرخوفكي
من
معنا مراسلة الجزيره عمر لافي ومن دنيتك
مراسل الجزيره امين درغامي نبدا معك عمر
لافي والوضع على جبهه مدينه بخموت
ربما رسميا اكتفت قياده الاركان بالحديث
عن ان القوات الاوكرانيه تمكنت من صد
الهجمات على مدينه مخموت هذا اضافه الى
تمكنها من صد هذه الهجمات على سبع محاور
قتال اخرى على طول خطوط المواجهه في اقليم
دومباز بالاضافه ايضا الى انها تحدثت عن
ان اكثر من 20 قريه في محيط محمود تعرضت
لقصف روسيا شديد بمختلف انواع الاسلحه هذا
رسميا لكن بالنسبه للمصادر العسكريه
الاوكرانيه التي تحدثنا معها عنها فواضح
ان هناك
دعني اصفها كما قالوا لنا هي اصلا حرب كسر
عظم لكن الذي يجري الان وخصوصا في الجبهه
الشماليه لبخمود هو تكثيف وزياده في هذه
الحرب منذ اصلا هي محاوله منذ فتره منذ
فتره طويله الدخول من المحور الشمالي لكن
الذي جرى في الليله الماضيه هو تكثيف شديد
كما قالوا لنا محاوله من هذا المحور
تحديدا على الرغم انه كما تعلم القتال
يدور في ثلاث محاور في الشمال الشمال
الشرقي وفي الشرق وفي الجنوب من بخموت لكن
هذا المحور هو الاعنف كما قالوا لنا واضح
ربما هناك قناعه يبدو عند القوات
الاوكرانيه وعد الاوكرانيين بشكل عام ان
روسيا تريد ان تحقق نصرا معنويا قبل
الرابع والعشرين من هذا الشهر هذا ما قاله
العديد من السياسيين ايضا وبالتالي هي
تلقي باعداد كبيره من القوات يقول
الاوكرانين بانها غير مدربه وتقتل باعداد
كبيره لكن هم يريدون تحقيق هذا النصر
وواضح ان الاوكرانيين يرفضون ان يمنحوها
هذه الفرصه وهذا ربما يفسر سبب الاستماته
الاوكرانيه في الدفاع عن مدينه محمود معنا
الرئيسكي قبل يومين تحدث عن ان محمود نعم
مدينه مهمه لكن ليست بالمدينه
الاستراتيجيه المهمه جدا بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا وقال بانه لن ندافع عنها حتى
اخر رجل والقى معه هنا بانه اذا ما تمكنت
القوات الروسيه من تطبيق هذه المدينه
تنسحب القوات الاوكرانيه ربما منها لكن
كما ذكرت لك لا يريدون ان يعطوا هذا النصر
المعنوي للقوات الروسيه كما ذكرت يعني
ميدانيا وتحديدا المعارك الان تجري في
المحور الشمالي وتحديدا عند قريه كركفكا
وايضا عند قريه هدمي في المحور الشمالي
لكن ايضا تتحدث القوات الاوكرانيه عن
تمكنها من صد هذه الهجمات ايضا اختم حسن
بان الجانب الانساني ايضا مهم المدينه
والثلاثه الاف شخص الذين يعيشون فيها
يتعرضون لقصف شديد قبل قليل اعلى مع حاكم
دونس عن ان اثنين من هؤلاء المدنيين قتلوا
في المدينه التي كان يسكنها اكثر من 70
الف والان يوجد فيها اقل من 3000 انسان
عامر لا في اتقان معنا ثمه روايه روسيه
اخرى ربما لسير المعارك على جبهه بخموت
امين
نعم حسن الروايه الروسيه تبدو متفائله جدا
بما يجري في بخموت خاصه في المحور الشمالي
الغربي من المدينه حيث الحديث الان يتركز
على
اقتحام دفاعات الجيش الاوكراني في المنطقه
الشماليه هذا الخط الدفاعي الاوكراني الذي
استعصى على القوات الروسيه منذ تقريبا ان
كانت القوات الروسيه قد سيطرت على مدينه
سوليدار والبعض البلدات والقرى المجاوره
لها وهذا لربما ما يفسر ما قال موقع ريبار
العسكري روسيا المتخصص بان هناك تحرك سريع
الان لقوات من الشمال باتجاه الشمال
الغربي وبعد السيطره على محطه قطارات
ستوبكي والان الاقتراب من بيرخوفكا وهي
احدى اهم ضواحي مدينه بخموت من الجهه
الشماليه الغربيه هذا لربما ي التزامن كما
قال الموقع مع دعم ناري وجوي كثيف من قبل
المدفعيه والطيران العسكري الروسي وهذا
يبدد في الحقيقه ما كان يجري الحديث عنه
خلال الايام القليله الماضيه حول اقله في
عدد يعني الذخائر والاسلحه لدى قوات فاجنر
والذي تحدث عنه مؤسس شركه فاجنر ايفغيني
بشكل صريح وواضح امس اذا ما قارنا ما قاله
امس مع حده
ويعني عنف هذه
الاشتباكات والمعارك فان ذلك يبدو متناقضا
شيئا ما في باقي المحاور وتحديدا فيكا
يبدو ان هناك ايضا زياده في الضغط العسكري
الروسي على معاقل الجيش الاوكراني في هذه
المدينه
المتاخمه لمدينه داني حيث نحن والتي
لطالما اتهم الموالون لروسيا الجانب
الاوكراني بقصف مدينه
واحيائها انطلاقا من هناك تطور مهم ولافت
يتمثل حسن في ان الجيش الروسي بدا
يستخدموا قنابل جويه من طراز باب 500 هذه
القنابل شديده الانفجار والتي كشف عنها
كشفت عنها وكاله قبل يومين يبدو ان
استعصاء دخول او اقتراب حتى القوات
الروسيه من دفاعات الجيش الاوكراني في هذه
المدينه
يبدو ان القياده العسكريه الروسيه خلصت
الى
ضروره قصف هذه المعاقل والتحصينات
العسكريه التي عمل الجيش الاوكراني على
بناءها وتشييدها بشكل جيد ومحكم على مدى
تسع سنوات اي منذ عام 2014 منذ اندلاع هذا
الصراع وربما محور
الان هي المرشحه لان تتصدر لربما العناوين
خلال الايام المقبله بحكم ما نشهده الان
من حده في المعارك وايضا القصف شكرا
المتبادل بين الجانبين من دنيتك من درغامي
وشكرا لعمر لافي من كراماتوس